部活始まった
質問を呼んでるんですよ最初必ずあの動画
の
全然動画見てないなかったら
全然動画見てないよねおー
頑張れこんにちははじめしゃちょーです
そして
富山に帰ってきたらこの男が偶然いました
こんにちは弟です
か
持って3年か3年近く会ってないってこと
でしょうお久しぶりです
すごいですね
兄弟でしたそんな3年ちゅうか合わなく
なるんだなっていう
確かにずっと思いましたね
そうね
動画にも
弟と動画
撮っておりましてえだって最後に出たの
大学生の時じゃないっていう大学の卒業し
て就職のちょっと前ちょっと前か
最後に誘います
という話をしたんだけどそれからもう3年
目ですか
社会人どうですか
[音楽]
[笑い]
就職する前に最後一緒に動画撮って
YouTuberにならないかと弟よ今
やればひょっとしたらその弟として
SEIKINさんHIKAKINさん
みたいなポーション気づけるんじゃないか
どうだいややめとくわ話をして早もう
あなた社会人4年目ですかそうですね
怖いよどうですか社会人はいやでもまあ
皆さん優しくておーいいね
約3年近く会ってないわけなんですけども
どこに住んでるの何してんの
新潟に住んでるの新潟で会社員をさせて
もらってますね
富山には帰ってくるの
うわーそれね
俺が家の話なんだけどそうだねいや知って
た俺3億円の家買ったんよ
兄弟
知らんわやばいよ
全然使ってない部屋とかあるから遊びに
行きなあじゃあ俺の部屋作ってもろて
コンビニ買い始めたよ
ちゃんと見てくれてるの
食べ物も飲み物も酒も無限にあるからその
辺はずっと残ってるよちょっと寄付して
なくなったりしたけど自分の欲しいものと
か家の中にコンビニ作りたくて戦ったんよ
気持ちはわからんでもない
棚を買って
並べてきれいに置いて
話が募るねさすがに
どうなんだろうね
[音楽]
あまり変わりなくなんか変わったことない
ん始める社長関係でこういうことがあった
みたいなはじめしゃちょー関係で一応さん
なんか顔が隠してるけどさ動画には出てる
わけじゃん声とかさあ何回かねバレたりし
たんばれたね
上がった外れたその弟ですか
先輩に言われたえーなんて答えたのそう
です
話が出るまでは何も言わずにいても
聞いてくれたと聞いていけないと多分いる
からそうよねそのままにして
言われたから答えるってことか
仕事動画に特にあの私のせいで支障とか出
てますね
[音楽]
兄弟というとね
SEIKINさんとHIKAKINさん
だけじゃなくて次サファイアンゲーム
面白かったんかなとか思っちゃいますけど
ね
なるほどね年を追うごとにちょっと思うん
だけどさこれ価値観にさ結構兄貴による
ところがやっぱ兄弟ってあると思うんで
中学ってさもう会談好きだから同じの
わかるけどさ高校も一緒だったわけじゃん
そうだね
入ってた部活もずっとバスケ部で一緒だっ
たからさやっぱ似てる部分は多いと思うぜ
環境が本当に
ほぼ同じで
上がってきてたからね
価値観が出てきたもんね
価値観っていうよりその面白いと思う
みたいなアニメとかさ
漫画とかさゲームとかさ音楽も割となんか
似たような
そうね環境が似てきたから似てきたって
いうか同じで育ったからね
YouTuber以降ちょっと
YouTuberになるのは
意外とさその20代半ばとかさガラッと
変わる人いるよやっぱり
仕事をなんとなく社会も見えて
こんな感じかと社外出てないんですけども
私どうもほんと社長
っぽいことは結構やってるよ
えでもそんなオーラも出始めてるんじゃ
ないそうね14位を雇ってからはちょっと
さすがにヘラヘラしてやんないからな
昔からなんやかんや
ヘラヘラしつつ閉めるとか締める人だと
思うけどねありがとうございますよ
[音楽]
国立大学受かってるのに辞退したんすよ
ほんでっています普通それでも行きたかっ
た場所があったんでしょとかやりたい場所
とか絶対こういうことというかさ
せて
大学行ってたからさなんか
聞いて話で母ちゃんから電話で
弟が国立大学受かったのに決断って聞いて
それどうしたのと思ってなんでなの
俺と同じパターンでこと天気は落ちてたん
よ
関西の方か富山大学の方とか
地元に残るか
関西に行くかっていう選択肢であなたの
元カノは
関西の方にいらっしゃったとこれはもう
関西ですね
知らない人もいるかもしれないですけど俺
も元カノが関東の方に行ったから関東に
行きたくて静岡大学私立も結構受けてたん
だけど結構東京のとか受けて向かってたん
よで本当は埼玉大学行きたかったんだけど
センターがちょびっと滑っちゃってて
ちょっと厳しいなーっていう話になって
そして動画大学にその時の俺からすると
地図近かったんよ静岡と茨城が実際行っ
たらなんか東京経由でめっちゃ遠いな
みたいになってて今結局別れたんですけど
なんか似たような理由でね大学は選んでた
のかなっていうそれはあるねあなた
すごいなそうだったのね
まあまあまあまあ分かるよ
兄貴が
県外出たっていうのは1つやっぱ非常に
なっちゃうよねそれ
はあるの楽しそうだったっすよ
手から離れて
遠くで過ごしてたまに帰ってくるみたいな
その方がなんか変化が欲しかったなって
いうのがあったかもそうね
話戻るんですけどさちょっと自慢じゃない
ですけどうちの家族すごいなって思わ思う
よ
兄弟2人じゃ俺たち
大学を暮らせてるんよ結構すごいなと思う
んですよって
数えてそんなめっちゃ好かれたってわけ
じゃないじゃんめっちゃにやらせてもらっ
てなんなら虫取りとかさ
外で遊びまくってバスケもなんかさせて
もらってさそうね勉強しろ勉強すると言わ
れてないわけようん間違いない確かに今
この立ったというかある程度下がってから
なんか両親ってすごい偉大だったなって何
の話をしてんの俺たちは真面目に25杯い
ないとこうなるよえだって今何歳26
ヤバい
2930円
いやーやばいなぁあの
[音楽]
家追い出されましたよ俺はねあの家では
絶対動画撮るなと実家に迷惑をかけちゃ
いけないってじいちゃんまーちゃんも住ん
でるからね追い出されて今動画撮ってる
わけですそれは弟の車でちょっとこっそり
な出てくる前に玄関でちょっぴり動画撮っ
ちゃった
[音楽]
3年近く会わないとさ開いたくならんかっ
たちょっぴりあ兄貴にあでもあったよあっ
たあったあるよね
良かった俺だけみたいな空気な
めっちゃ恥ずかしいなっちゃいますけど
この都市になってねこの距離感というか
なかなか会えない兄弟になってからさ
やっぱたまに家族恋しくなる時ってあるよ
なあれねー
[音楽]
でもいいねいいねたまに
俺も最近ね週1でバスケするようにしてん
なあそうなんやさすがにちょっと運動する
場がなさすぎてさやんないとと思ってなん
か気になってることがないんすか最近の
始める社長ではじめしゃちょーで
兄としてでもいいんですけど
兄としてそれこそ兄貴の
趣味って何最近ねこの間動画見てる人また
こいつ話だしよっていうかもしれないです
けどサウナですね
俺ちょっと辛いとこが逃げ方でさあその
有名なというかここは行くべきさんだ
みたいななんかね新潟さテントサウナ
なんかちょくやってる
えいいじゃんバスティに座間誘ってくれた
人がめっちゃテント差あるんですよなんか
ハードル高いなって思いながらサウナって
何がいいちょっと教えてよサウナはねいや
まずは
知ってる人についていくのが一番いいかな
俺えだってさサウナ入ってるやつ絶対ない
でしょないないないない
嫌いだと思うちょっと1回行ってみて
ほしいかな
整うの覚えればマジ合法麻薬だからね
そして弟だよなんとはじめしゃちょー
チャンネル登録者数1000万人いきまし
た知ってましたか知ってましたね
全部知ってるね
そうだよね
すごいでもなんか家族でさんのLINEし
てんのちょっといいよね
[音楽]
子供の頃はとてもない喧嘩時代を送って
から仲良くなってるからね
めっちゃ喧嘩してたよね昔
からね
[音楽]
ブリッツだよねでも遊び相手だとは思って
たよね今この目線から
俺のこと俺の幼少期を考えると今日うざい
やつだったなと思うよその年齢的にその
メタ兄貴についていこうとするとかさある
でも結構やんちゃっ子だったじゃん
やんちゃな弟だったじゃん
怖いもん俺の子供が自分だったら俺マジで
怖いもん
知らないと思いますけど彼のやんちゃ度は
中学校もバスケやってたんですけどもその
クラブの最後の引退試合の写真の1ページ
の彼のポジションを見たらわかると思うん
ですがこれですよこれはどう見ても
やんちゃ子なんですよこのやんちゃな弟で
はあったけどやっぱゲームとかちゃんと
遊んでくれたしさボール遊びとかしてくれ
たから普通に楽しかったただその生意気
だったあなたは多分思ってたのかなって
いういや
本当にやべえやつ
だったけど
弟の方が実はだったっていうでもちゃんと
そういうのは
ありますからなんか自信持っていい加速だ
なっていう本当に俺は素敵なことだなって
最近数子を意識し出したりさ結婚とか
考えで出てるキスじゃん吊るしないわ
オイルトップにですけどなんかいい家族に
呼ばれてよかったなって
ねだってもう
富山出てどれぐらい俺18の時に出てる
から11年だ
富山が流れて8年
8年ぐらいかな10年近く出てると変わる
よね
富山もどう思う今から俺チューリップフェ
アっていうその地元のマジの地元の
イベントに出るんですけどもお兄ちゃんが
さあのチューリップフェアに出るって思っ
たなんか
普通のイベントでちょっと感覚が違ってさ
みんなで楽しむやつじゃんお祭りというか
もうあのお祭りで出るの
ゲストとして結構すごいなと思って普段の
お仕事とかのイベントと地元でイベントっ
てなんか感覚違っててあの地元のスターっ
て言いたいわけじゃないっすけどちょっと
なんかすごいと思ったよ
地元のスターかな
地元というかもう富山県っていう単位で
多分スターではなかなか
柴田理恵さんちょっとね久々に地元の時代
イベントだよねもう1台イベントよ俺たち
が住んでる街の結構でっかいのに出るから
うわー感慨深いなって思ってあとコロナで
延期になってるよねああそっか本当に去年
来るよねちょっとそういうのでもようやく
できたかとまあちょっとコロナに気をつけ
つつイベントは行ってくるわこの後で
悲しいことにより今日帰るからさ静岡
早いよねー
[音楽]
東京の静岡もよくいるからタイムが今行き
ますでも
じゃあ頑張ろうぜ
[音楽]